guess I'll just start with with the
first and the very obvious have you been
watching the miniseries and what do you
think so well I haven't watched a
miniseries at all not at all not at all
not a minute why so loved it would you
look at a clip or you resolute well you
know about a clip this is the n-word
soon it'll force the black Jews to make
a choice whose side are you on the man
or the Brothers
yes what do you think of the casting I
thought Denzel should have played me or
Ezra should have played me it's yourself
oh yeah or you know Will Smith why not
not Will Smith you know good actor but
you know light-skinned it chris darden
can joke about the casting the former OJ
prosecutor is played by Sterling Kay
brown but Darden's dead serious about
the topic of compensation he hasn't
received a cent from the hugely
successful FX series the People vs OJ
Simpson the producers of that show
should have reached out to me and I
would have liked them to have
compensated me because I feel that from
what I have heard about the series
obviously they're taking things from my
life outside of the courtroom and
they've also taken things I believe out
of my book in contempt
and I feel like they should have
compensated me for that the series is
based on journalist Jeffrey Toobin book
the run of his life and sales are up 900
percent it portrays the prosecution team
as kind of bumbling does it a little
yeah well you know what you know my book
was on the New York Times bestseller
list for 24 weeks I understand that one
way people you know make money off of me
where your mistakes is by casting in the
negative
the series suggests that this
unforgettable moment was a debacle for
Darden do you regret having him try on
the glove no I think that the glove
demonstrations one of the greatest
courtroom scenes in a American history
the less fit the one argue about it
yeah that's okay is it true that f lee
Bailey came up to you before court and
said to you if you don't ask him to try
on the glove I will if you don't ask him
to try on the gloves I will I don't
recall that I don't recall that
happening okay but what about rumors of
a romance with Marcia Clark the series
hints that something could have happened
can we talk a little bit about Marcia
smile was there a relationship what does
that mean a relationship that's a good
question I'd like to ask him now what
does that mean awesome that's what I'm
trying to find out would you say that
you guys dated